in a root canal used to have sweaters
like that what it's not the Michigan
you'd have a crocodile knitted into a
heavy slightly I've never been able to
thank you face-to-face for giving me the
gift of Rutger Hauer in boxer briefs in
the ring I've seen see Superman nice man
and he came up with that little speech
yes he wrote it one o'clock the morning
I was going to be fired at free laughter
and then soon said work towards a dog so
when boom boom would through the rain to
his trailer he's sitting there saying I
haven't written a speech on no and he
said no no no sit down and listen and he
said okay ready cook and he read it and
it was great I said you stole I said no
I just wrote it so that's what we're
gonna do
I've seen damn anyone really it was a
hunter's line same time to dive it's
kind of nice time
the lead up to it I've seen thing we do
nothing starships and without the
doorbell together attack ships on fire
off shore over lion
all those moments will be lost in time
like tears run during all of five words
digitally you say it so it's like a
Shelley point yeah
you